vamos a construir nuestra intuición
sobre cómo sumar y restar vectores de
una manera visual así que para empezar
vamos a decir que tengo un vector a un
vector y ya este vector
le voy a sumar un vector b a este evento
y les voy a sumar un vector b y bueno
voy a decir que la suma de estos dos me
va a dar otro vector el cual le voy a
poner el nombre de c el vector a más el
vector b me dan el vector c entonces
cómo podríamos hacer un diagrama de esta
ecuación si estos son vectores en dos
dimensiones primero voy a dibujar por
aquí a mi vector
entonces si lo pongo por aquí voy a
suponer que no sé se me ocurre que este
sea mi vector am así que déjame ponerle
nombre este de aquí va a ser mi vector
y bueno me voy a tomar también a un
y como se lo estuvo sumando al vector am
entonces voy a decir que el vector de se
ve como esto ojo voy a poner su punto
inicial en donde está el punto final del
vector a y después voy a dibujar al
vector b que bueno voy a suponer que se
ve así y déjame ponerle su respectivo
nombre este de aquí va a ser mi vector
ve ahora cómo se va a ver mi vector c
bueno pues este vector se va a tener
como punto inicial el punto inicial del
vector a va a empezar justo aquí y va a
tener como punto final el punto final
del vector b es decir va a terminar aquí
entonces esto de aquí de aquí acá va a
ser la suma de estos dos vectores este
de color azul
va a ser mi vector
y vector se lo más importante que quiero
mencionarte aquí es que cuando yo sumo
dos vectores tengo que poner en la
cabeza del primero la cola del segundo
para así poder sumar los ahora hay que
ser cuidadosos con esto ya que si estoy
sumando el orden no importa pude haber
hecho esto exactamente al revés y decir
si me tomo el vector b ya éste le sumó
el vector a déjame cambiar a mi vector
am bueno pues esto nos va a dar de
respuesta también el vector cm también
el vector c y cómo lo podemos
representar de una manera visual bueno
sería un diagrama un poco distinto pero
se va a ver más o menos así vamos a
llegar al mismo lugar
entonces si empiezo esta vez con el
vector b y vamos a suponer que este
punto de aquí es nuestro punto inicial
es nuestro punto de origen no
forzosamente tienes que estar en el
origen
pero bueno digamos que este es el origen
para hacerlo un poco más sencillo si
empezamos con el vector de aquí va a
empezar y lo voy a dibujar justo por acá
se va a ver más o menos así más o menos
así se ve nuestro vector b estás de
acuerdo aquí voy a poner que este es
nuestro rector b ya este le voy a sumar
el vector am recuerda voy a empezar en
la cabeza del vector b y bueno a partir
de aquí va a empezar mi vector am que se
ve más o menos así recuerdas empezamos
en el punto final de ven eso es muy
importante y se ve más o menos
si estás de acuerdo de tal manera que
este va a ser mi vector a este de aquí
es mi sector am y ahora observa que de
hecho llegamos de nuevo al vector se en
su punto inicial está en dónde está el
punto inicial del vector ven y su punto
final está en dónde está el punto final
del vector a es decir que si empiezas
con el vector ven y le sumas el vector
am llegas al mismo vector resultante
llamado c te darán la misma cosa y es
por esa razón que puse estas dos
operaciones una abajo de la otra
llegando a la misma respuesta ahora qué
te parece si pensamos en la resta del
vector am - el rector ven y esto nos va
a dar otra cosa completamente distinta
lo voy a poner por aquí al vector am le
vamos a restar el vector de le vamos a
restar el vector b y bueno voy a suponer
que me va a dar de resultado
doctor de un nuevo vector y ahora ten
cuidado aquí el orden importa no es lo
mismo empezar con el vector a y quitarle
el vector ver que lo contrario entonces
nuestro vector a se veía más o menos así
recuerdas voy a suponer que por aquí
está mi punto inicial y se ve más o
menos
de esta forma recuerda que este es un
dibujo hecho a mano no por eso está
perfectamente bien hecho pero tú tienes
la idea de qué es lo que está pasando
este de aquí va a ser mi vector am y
ahora una forma de pensar en restar al
vector b es que en lugar de sumar al
vector b como hicimos en el caso
anterior podemos sumar el vector b
negativo o menos bien entonces b
negativo o menos b va a empezar en el
punto final de amd y después se va a
mover en dirección contraria a cómo se
movía bien así que si b va en esta
dirección
v va a ir en dirección contraria ojo va
a tener la misma magnitud pero dirección
contraria así que pues hagámoslo voy a
tomarme a menos ve que se va a ver más o
menos así por aquí va a estar menos bien
espero que sea un buen dibujo así que
por aquí voy a tomarme a menos b o en
negativo algo así lo podemos ver observa
que tiene la misma magnitud que ven la
misma magnitud que ve pero sentido
contrario sólo lo volteamos 180 grados
ahora ya que tenemos aa y al vector
- bm o b negativo cuál va a ser nuestro
vector resultante de bueno pues va a
tener como punto inicial el punto
inicial de amd como punto final el punto
final de menos ver y entonces se va a
ver de la siguiente manera va a ser
el vector que tengo aquí este vector que
tengo aquí va a ser igual al resultado
de tomarme el vector am y restarle el
vector b o dicho de otra manera sumarme
al vector am y sumarle el vector menos b
o el vector b negativo muy bien ahora
que ya vimos todo esto y tenemos todo
este conocimiento qué te parece si
hacemos un ejercicio pero que sea al
revés te voy a dar algunos diagramas y
tú me vas a decir la ecuación
correspondiente así que empecemos por
dibujar uno interesante se me ocurre
tomarme este caso voy a decir que no sé
con este color voy a poner a nuestro
vector am voy a decir que este es
nuestro vector am así que le voy a poner
nombre nuestro vector
y bueno por aquí tengo a nuestro vector
voy a decir que este va a ser nuestro
vector ven muy bien vamos a ponerle
nombre este de aquí es nuestro vector b
y ahora voy a decir que este de aquí va
a ser nuestro vector ce este de aquí va
a ser nuestro vector
y te invito a que pases el vídeo y vea
si puedes escribir una ecuación que
defina esta relación que tengo justo
aquí bueno pues este caso está muy
interesante porque date cuenta que todos
están en un ciclo o lo podrías ver como
un círculo cada uno empieza en donde
está la cabeza del otro así que como
podemos encontrar una expresión que
represente este diagrama que tenemos
aquí bueno pues si me dices que el
vector a más el vector bm del vector se
recuerda que el vector se tendría que ir
en dirección contraria es decir su punto
inicial tendría que ir en el punto
inicial de amd y su punto final debería
estar en el punto final de ver pero este
caso está al revés tenemos el punto
inicial del vector c en el punto final
del vector am y el punto final del
vector c en el punto inicial del vector
aun entonces cómo podemos resolver este
problema bueno pues en lugar de tomarnos
al vector se que te parece si pensamos
en él
puesto del vector ce es decir en lugar
de tomarnos el vector ce vamos a
tomarnos al vector
- cm y entonces puedo voltear esto se va
a ver de la siguiente manera el vector
- se lo voy a poner con el mismo color
va a ir en dirección contraria recuerdas
tiene la misma magnitud pero va a ir en
dirección contraria este es mi vector
menos sea o sea negativo y date cuenta
que este vector menos sem tiene como
punto inicial el punto inicial del
vector am y como punto final el punto
final del vector ven justo lo que
queríamos ahora que lo volteamos sigue
teniendo la misma magnitud pero
dirección contraria que ponemos con este
signo y esto nos facilita mucho
construir la ecuación porque ahora sí le
puedo decir que sí a este vector a sea
este vector
yo le sumó este vector ven yo le sumó
este vector b entonces esto nos va a dar
como respuesta quién
bueno pues observa que el vector a si le
sumamos el vector b entonces nos da como
respuesta este vector que tengo aquí es
decir menos cm y ahora sí puedo escribir
que el vector
además el vector b es igual al vector c
negativo o menos c y ya está
llegamos a la respuesta así que espero
que esto te haya parecido muy
interesante